tributes to the lives lost on that night
in 2017
have been happening all over the valley
today from downtown las vegas to the new
allegiance stadium
but we begin tonight where the tragedy
began
sasha loftis joining us now live from
the route 91 concert grounds where
survivors and families joined hands
tonight
sasha
denise and brian this was just a
beautiful thing to see today
survivors joined the family and friends
of the fallen
to commemorate them three years since
this dark day
candace bowers
[Music]
the group started with a reading of
names behind the concert grounds
they commemorated each person with a
photo and the ringing of a bell
they then walked to las vegas boulevard
and stood in a group across from
mandalay bay
we saw so many people stare up at that
building with tears in their eyes
we spoke with a few survivors tonight
who say as horrific as it was to go
through this
they're grateful to be a part of this
amazing community
we're really grateful that we can stand
here three years later
and join together and and know that
you know out of a horrible tragedy there
was this
wonderful family that was born and so
we know that wherever we go when we see
the little decals on the cars
or the t-shirts or the hats or whatever
we know that
there's family around
metro police shut down guile street so
the group could hold this memorial
safely there was also a moment where
those here cheered for metro police the
ones that were here
blocking the road and thanked them for
their response on that day three years
ago
there was also as you see behind me a
memorial flowers
things like that to commemorate the
anniversary of the one october shooting
reporting live sasha loftis 8 news now